the Avenger is back and the hook is
waiting Peter Pan it's the 25th
anniversary of Hook we suffered out my
best Rufio with the Lost Boys and pug
all grown up
goofy oh don't ask
thud but and the rest of the Lost Boys
reunited for an epic throwback photo
shoot 25 years in the making and they
filmed they were all different ages they
were about 6 to 16 17 so really to see
them all together now 25 years later
they're all the same producer Bryan Polk
crass got the gang back together and
recreated their iconic looks from the
movie now many people realize for the
Lost Boys the costumes they're in is
what they wear the entire film they're
going to wear the same thing throughout
the entire duration of their life and
never land because they never age does
it feel like 25 years as practice oh
yeah we're old now for Dante Bosco the
reunion meant slipping back into those
tights and showing off that midriff
when you did this outfit which looks
totally cool now when you're 15 and
you're you know you're know you're going
to be in this Steven Spielberg movie
with mega star Robin Williams and Dustin
Hoffman and Julie Roberts you know you
know you want to be cool
I don't know how cool I'm gonna look at
my belly button down years laters
becomes this iconic iconic look that uh
people cosplay all over the world it's
so so cool like I'm spying financial Pig
you lewd crude rude bag of Prichard food
dude the reunion also marks the second
anniversary of Robin Williams death it
was so so very just as goofy as he was
gentle yeah yeah you have to sit very uh
very alive
only to know that that he had the right
ship but each and every one of us ah
every time I pass by me go oh my grunts
boy my brother more that was I think his
power was his reach and being able to
make anybody even through a television
screen or a movie screen make you feel
so great
oh dear are you going Peter is there
anything you want to tell him or
something
a message you wish you could have said
to him before he passed in the world and
nobody confessing to us and that you
know we're a lot of the things that we
became all these years later are
directly because of him dying what using
your imagination Peter
you